[Music]
show
oh yeah what kind of camera Bell Howell
35 millimeter
uh is it a 2708 model or 2709
I'm not sure is there a big difference
um yeah hey Donnie
the guy up here wants to know if there's
a big difference between a 2708 and a
2709 okay
do you have either nope every camera's
been loaned out one's coming back in
half an hour though if I were but it's
2709 okay 30 minutes for the 20 seconds
30 minutes
seven in Greek zero nine
are you married
my wife died oh I'm terribly sorry
hey next part before we'll come in
she's back in the days
when we used to cry in shape and
if you got it
I've come
five minute warning for Miss Moore
that's mine
uh you're gonna look at least 90 in this
traffic we've got an eight part sign out
process let me go try to find a pin
what's going on
[Laughter]
I thought it was Luke yes
can't cry just some random horror from
Holocaust
cut
I uh I'm Ellie Leroy
so we going again
Sorry God you gave us a beautiful light
and I squandered it don't have any light
now oh
come on my camera's here my camera's
here
action
I'm gonna try something do you think it
could hold your discussion so eyes water
for two and on the third beat I'm gonna
do a right effect and that's when you go
what if you do yeah yes okay let's do it
remove any notes on my entrance
[Music]
before you Mr Conrad
lights and tears
[Laughter]
this is nuts but could you by any chance
try the same thing with less tears
what's your turn
[Laughter]
let's do this
it was really a goodness
Floyd the toes were
with
cameras up the hill Mr Congress
yeah we'd better hurry
there
oh my beautiful baby boy come come okay
right here but then I remember you are
sad and lonely man right here
no one will ever love you but her and
she's only in your head okay last look
do I know her
no she's in your head
no no no last look no last let's get up
gotta kill you you're losing the light
we roll now we roll roll
hmm
music
and action
[Music]
action
they probably
[Applause]
now look at this more
you're trying to hide the shame
Hold Steady
[Music]
foreign